but they're still sticking with him
giving him some minutes letting him try
to get in the flow
Jake loravia inside there's a technical
foul called
good Shackleford it's our first flap
foul
there we go that's that's yeah that was
interesting well he's saying he got hit
in the chin and he did I thought he did
too I thought he took straight contact
but it just was wasn't noticed by the
officials
but the Flop rule this year is going to
be always controversial because it's
each official sees it the other way but
the the penalty is assessed by game
officials the opposing team awarded one
free throw and this is the big one is
the is is the possession of the ball
and help me out here you cannot
challenge that
no that that's a that's an official's
opinion on the Fly
and I'm just saying that because the
replay really tells the story right
that's why it's experimental
yeah it was a late ad about three days
before summer league started up
had to be reviewed by the rules
committee and they decided let's give it
a try and see what happens whistle on
that dribble Drive Inside by Jang
foreign
look I'm not the one that got hit in the
chop so
he definitely took a foreign
[Music]
and that's the thing about a lot of
players too they will get hit and
overplayed but then they'll overplay it
they'll pull the Clint Eastwood on you
have some great acting right and it just
sells it I mean
is this an obvious question but is it a
flop if you don't actually flop down
like don't you need to follow up to make
it a flop no I think flop by definition
I think what you saw was is an
exaggeration exaggeration as he extended
backwards
yeah yeah I think that's part of what uh
and it's going to be controversial you
can tell already just on that call crowd
went to look at the replay and that's
that's going to be the issue as well who
sees why and how and listen this is also
training ground for these officials they
are training in summer league and so
they'll have these conversations and
they might have the instruction that we
don't know yet about you know what
they're considering collapse
big time pass walk it again try to
slip a pass into Williams Jr
the tree flops in the woods there oh
yeah yeah that's that oh definitely you
took it in the job so the reaction was a
little delayed but he definitely took
the hit bam to the reaction and so
that's the question you know should he
have reacted as soon as he got hit these
are officials we're watching it in slow
motion right so ours does look delayed